[Music]
[Applause]
we spent a lot of time talking about tom
brady joining fox eventually when his
career is over and we thought the
numbers might be 20 to 25 million
dollars a year and then you realize fox
is bringing him in as a brand ambassador
and also to do color on their football
games and i thought john skipper one of
the brightest people i ever encountered
in my career former espn uh ceo
president and he's now the co-founder
and ceo of metal metal arc media working
with dan levitard and uh john thanks for
joining us uh your reaction when you
first heard the news that fox was going
to offer
that kind of money to tom brady
i have to confess my first reaction was
not about the um
money but about potentially how well
fox played this
right everybody was surprised that they
let joe buck and troy aikman
go
troy aikman was surprised that they had
not even
uh
really been in touch with him about it
and i think perhaps this explains it
right they uh planned all along that
they were going to get brady i have no
idea if that's right by the way but
that's the first thing i thought is wow
look how well they play this
they they're going to get uh the goat
into the booth
how do you hide something like that john
i have no idea
although i am here somewhere in the
midwest in the witness protection
program
so
uh so it is possible to keep secrets and
look to your first point it is a lot of
money
and uh it raises the inevitable question
how you how you justify spending quite
so much money it's not because of
ratings it does not have any effect on
the ratings uh and i've never had
anybody show me any data to dispute that
this is more about just what you're
talking about uh pride a brand
ambassador g will take our important
advertisers by the booth to see tom
brady uh gee i suspect he will see him
at the upfront presentations at some
point in the not too distant future so
you can make
a justification for it uh
but
it's not about ratings or those more
people will watch or even because it
will be a better or worse broadcast it's
just about the
jazz of having tom brady but also i was
wondering and it seems like an obvious
question john but i don't think many
people are asking
is tom brady going to be any good as an
analyst
i'm not sure it matters other than
there'll be a little bit of
embarrassment
look he's a he's a smart guy he's
charming i'm assuming he'll be that to
me the interesting the judgment of
whether it's going to be any good is he
going to provide insight
now you can provide insight in a number
of things right one of them is and tony
romo gets credit for being spectacular
about this right which is insight into
what play is going to be called why it's
being played i think tom will do pretty
well there the other insight you want is
what is it like what are the players
like who's a good guy who's a bad guy is
tom brady really going to be willing to
say anything
controversial uh
i suspect he will be careful he's a very
guarded guy right if you think about the
life he leads and how he
manages the information that comes out
of his mouth he's pretty guarded i don't
think he's going to be controversial i
don't think he'll be provocative he
won't be any charles barkley
right
uh and that's what you like is somebody
who's fun insightful
that you want to sit with so he'll be
okay i don't think it'll be a disaster
we talked about this a couple of weeks
ago charles mark barkley might be the
most valuable
member of the sports media
right you agree
yes i do and i think there's only
three or four people in the history
of uh broadcasting who you genuinely can
say that people tune in to see them
right the late great john madden uh who
just recently passed uh
um was one of those guys barkley right
now is the guy in all of sports you can
say people will turn in to see him
did you try to get barkley at espn
absolutely
absolutely there's almost nobody who's
really really good we didn't try to get
the biggest issue with espn was
uh and you know this so we'll have a
little fun with this is espn wants you
to work too damn hard
we weren't we weren't willing to pay
uh i i want to remember talking to shaq
who's a very good guy very friendly and
i tried very hard to convince him you
don't want to be the second field of
shack time sorry to charles come over to
his pen you'll be the star
and he said i already talked to charles
and cheryl said all i got to do is show
up
uh
and i don't have to rehearse i don't
have to be on sportscenter i don't have
to be on first date i don't have to be
on pti i don't have to be on nba
countdown i can just work come in sit
down and uh chew it up and uh so yeah it
was hard to get him i remember talking
to barkley barkley said uh
hey espn is uh interested in
signing me and i said well let me tell
you why you shouldn't do it
where you're gonna have to go every day
or every other day or you know you're
gonna have to be on espn radio you're
gonna have to be on you you go through
the car wash there you gotta know the
weather is gonna be an issue you go
through the car wash there
and i i said you could do that or i'm
gonna guess tnt is just gonna say hey
just show up and that's uh have some fun
and he said yeah this shouldn't be a
hard decision
yeah he's right and we knew we were
operating with that disadvantage of
course the other worked for us because
we had so much programming to fill and
we needed guests and we and we cared a
lot about getting our money's worth so
uh
so yeah it was a disadvantage and i do
not blame shaq or charles they are
sitting where they should be and by the
way let me say another thing dan which i
think you'll agree with for all the
worrying about preparation and all the
best show
uh in some ways the best sports studio
show
in all of sports is that charles barkley
shaq kenny smith ernie johnson show and
it's because they look like they're
having fun they know what they're
talking about they're willing to be
provocative they're willing to to uh
mash it up and uh it's great
well john you're saying it right to my
face that that's the best studio show
and i thought that i was part of the
best studio show
i mean well you were you were part of
the best sports information studio show
not the game day
uh pre and posts and halftime shows i
should make that distinction okay all
right fair enough uh the manning cast
where are we going with imitators with
the manning cast in your opinion
um i think the manningcast is
terrifically entertaining what we're
what we're doing is pretending that
everything in the booth is great we're
doing the game the way we should do it
so if we're going to have fun or we're
going to not call every play it's got to
be an alternative broadcast
i i personally think
it's it's a funny attempt to get
actually different voices on the game
who aren't just calling third and eight
and they turn around and hand the ball
off but every i think what will be
interesting is when somebody does that
in the
in the first booth not in an alternative
oh
okay so you're tuning into that game and
this is the game it's not alternative
programming
yes huh okay
yeah i tried to do that one time with uh
tony kornheiser
and uh the football gods the football
gods rebelled it was a little like uh
you know when uh paris took took a hell
in detroit uh all of the football gods
uh sent their forces in uh ships across
the weinberg sea and uh tried to
uh execute tony
what's the craziest idea you almost
succeeded with at espn that you were
going to try
you remember anything that was
out outside the box
i think i think that
tony kornheiser was the biggest example
right we were trying to interject into a
booth comedy and different kind of
flavor
um
and it did not work
uh by the way tony did great work it
wasn't bad it just uh there wasn't an
overall general acceptance that that was
the right way to go
so i uh and and let me stipulate too i
didn't produce a lot of football games
so
it's possible i don't know what i'm
talking about he's john skipper the uh
co-founder and ceo of meadowlark media
with dan levitard former uh president of
espn give me a sport that you would
invest in right now if it was a stock
aside from the nfl you got a another
sport
uh sure and i did and uh in this case i
just said you know i could be wrong uh
here's a case where i was not wrong
which is soccer right soccer i just read
something the other day that suggested
is now the fourth most popular sport
in the country headed to number three
behind football and basketball uh and it
is of course about by now you don't need
nostradamus to tell you this everybody
knows this right uh nbc just paid
a large sum of money and a big increase
in this premier league espn ball la liga
and bundesliga champions league is a
smash from cbs
uh soccer soccer's coming and
and uh other than football and
basketball everybody should watch out
the other one is of course we saw this
weekend and on this one i was wrong and
that's f1 yeah f1 is coming yeah and uh
they've done a fabulous job the drive to
survive show has helped but uh to have a
sport grow that fast in the united
states with no u.s participants is
pretty remarkable no participants at the
highest at the highest level and you got
a younger demo that's watching formula
one and uh you know you got the
beautiful people that showed up for it
presents itself well you got celebrities
you got the weather you know you're
you're racing on the same streets that
people can drive on on any other day so
there is some fascination with that but
baseball's been good at the local level
john yes
baseball's uh i'm not denigrating any
other sport baseball thrives at the
local level it thrives as a spectacular
daily sport i talked to a buddy of mine
yesterday what was he doing he's going
to the white sox game in the afternoon
uh so the local adherents are like daily
communicates and uh it works very well
that way but should they be worried
should the commissioner be worried about
the national audience national
perception of
baseball as a sport
of course they should be right and there
are some solves for it right the issue
is there have not been enough national
gains one of the
great benefits of um
of the nfl and it's its contracted
schedule and uh scarcity of games is
everybody in the country you can see
every team
you i i defy you absent some very
expensive absent mlb
calm or whatever the digital package is
called you can't see the marlins and
padres play if you live in chicago or
cleveland unless you have a couple
hundred dollar package nobody sees any
of the baseball teams until the post
season
except the yankees the red sox and the
dodgers and
and a couple of others
before i let you go would you
have signed tom brady to that deal if
you were at espn and would you have made
an offer like that
no
but espn reportedly did you know they
were involved in the uh sweepstakes for
tom brady
they were involved and uh someone else
is running espn and doing a fine job but
when i was there i did not believe
that i would never pay this kind of
money
uh for those athletes
what kind of money would you pay that
money for joe buck and troy aikman
um look once again every time anybody
came up i went by and talked to him i
went by and spoke with joe buck
and we would love to have had joe buck
but we were not willing to pay
the amount of money it would take to get
him and then we tried to bridge the gap
by doing what we talked about in the
beginning right then we'll give you 15
other things to do then maybe we can
justify it and remember to we had a
thousand talents and every time we hired
somebody
everybody else thought their salary need
to be recalibrated
so it's a different beast espn's a
different mechanism but they want to
play and they're right they they want to
play in the in the top level game with
their nfl football and it's probably a
good idea
well it feels like espn spent all of its
money on just getting these leagues uh
as opposed to the talent whereas some of
the other networks you know they they
were forced to spend a little bit more
on their time you know tony romo kind of
changed everything didn't he yes yes he
did and look again espn is
overwhelmingly about volume right the
point and by the way they're buying the
right thing you have to choose am i
going to buy more rights where i'm going
to pay
uh play-by-plan by playing analysts more
money i would choose more rights yeah
john it's great to talk to you as always
and uh hope you're doing well thanks for
joining us
okay thank you dan i look forward to
seeing you in the neighborhood one day
well maybe we'll show up at levitard's
next wedding
oh please please
no no he's not going to have any more
winnings forget i said that no no this
is the one and only no no
man is buried forever the anniversary
part the anniversary party how's that
my bad i misspoke thank you john that's
uh john skipper my former boss
co-founder ceo of metal arc media